[MUSIC PLAYING]
In my sophomore year I
walked onto the crew team,
and it completely
changed my life.
Having that outlet
for stress helps
me enjoy both parts of my
life, both the athletic
and the academic
side, a lot more.
[CHATTER, CLATTERING]
We really just have an
amazing team culture.
I learn a lot from the
people that I'm around.
They definitely
inspire me to be better
on the water and academically.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Most of the undergrad residences
are within like a five
or so minute walk
from the boathouse.
We're at the boathouse now,
and that's an undergrad dorm.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We kind of all push each other
to become the fastest boats
that we can be, but
at the same time,
in order to become the
best versions of ourselves,
we have to be supportive of
each other throughout the way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The entire crew just
rowing as one person,
you're all moving at
the exact same time.
The oars are clicking in
exactly the same rhythm.
The boat is surging through
the water at the tempo
that you set.
That is just such an incredibly
magical moment that I've never
experienced anywhere else.
We're Division One.
In the spring
we'll definitely be
rowing against a bunch of
the Ivies and Dartmouth,
Georgetown.
We have some races
out in San Diego.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Charles is definitely
a very historic river
in the rowing community.
Head of the Charles is one of
the most well-known regattas
in the world.
Going through all the bridges
and hearing about all the turns
that I've heard about for
so long and then just like
rowing that every single day,
it's like it never gets old.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm sort of driven by the
competitive aspect of it.
I just love racing.
In the fall we do
sort of the big,
name brand races like
the Head of the Charles.
We go up to the Head of
the Fish in New York.
Being completely gassed and
just dead after the finish line,
but then you see the other
boat two or three seats back,
that's a great feeling.
You're erging for the
whole winter season
and then the payoff
is that moment when
you sprint in the
last 200 meters,
pass another boat by a hair,
and you get the medals,
you get the trophy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]